And, obviously, the answers, are all of these.
It is a pain to change. We've basically hard-coded
these percent s's here and there and we're doing
this complicated logic to put everything together. That is
zero fun. We don't get any syntax highlighting. That's
correct. Because we're putting HTML in our Python code.
So, we're not dealing with HTML. We're basically dealing
with big strings. And that's really tedious to manipulate
when your editor is set up to write Python. Our code is
ugly. I didn't have a whole lot of fun explaining that code
to you. I can't imagine you had a whole lot of fun
listening to me attempt to do so. We can certainly make things
a lot more clear. And it's error prone. You know if you
miss one of those percent s's, you get a percent s in
your output. If you want to, you know, add extra things, it's very
difficult to reason about and kind of figure out what goes where.
So this is, obviously, not a particularly great approach
for generating HTML from our web application. It works for
short, little things like just a simple, simple tiny
form. But anything more complicated than that is very unwieldy.